I have a special treat for you today and
it's of the tables being turned on the
bully as many of you know I relish and
thrive on social awkwardness and
yesterday we had it in droves on the
national stage and we're gonna look at
it together today and when I say the
tables were turned on the bully I mean
of course Donald Trump Donald Trump who
bullies everyone on Twitter in person
threatening people with prison making
fun of their disabilities making fun of
their appearance threatening them with
getting them fired all of that stuff
he's the quintessential bully the tables
were very much turned yesterday at
George HW Bush's funeral at the National
Cathedral in DC I was sort of watching
this off and on as I prepared
yesterday's show and at one point Donald
Trump seemed to be sleeping which we'll
get to later but at all times Donald
Trump looked completely miserable
because he was the odd one out among
adults quite frankly he was the loser
beta not respected or even acknowledged
by some of the people that were there
and when Donald Trump first walked in he
walked over to where all of the
presidents were sitting and President
Obama very graciously greeting Melania
Trump Donald Trump immediately sort of
unsure how to handle himself and he
shakes Barack Obama's hand and Barack
Obama sort of looks lukewarm Michelle
Obama straight-up looks disgusted with
him and then the Clintons don't even
look over or move Bill and Hillary
Clinton look like statues as Donald
Trump enters the Carters don't even care
about Trump one way or the other they're
checking their watches and looking at
the program there they're not even
considering interrupting what they're
doing to greet Donald Trump and it was
delightfully awkward and why should they
be nice to Trump this goes beyond common
courtesy right Trump was the leader of
the birther movement against Barack
Obama and slams him daily Trump said
Hillary Clinton should be in prison and
considered directing the Justice
Department to prosecute her
he's called Jimmy Carter the second
worst president ever behind brocco bomb
so what I say Pat is good for them Trump
looked just as miserable there as he did
in Argentina among world leaders who act
like adults and simply don't see Donald
Trump as an adult that they're at their
level I say good for them because
they're doing what the rest of the world
is increasingly doing which is they see
Trump as a joke as a sort of
inconvenience that is there
plain and simple if there's anyone else
I would sort of feel bad it's like this
person's not being part of the community
he's not let in in the club but Donald
Trump deserves it so I don't feel bad at
all
he was only even at George HW Bush's
funeral because George HW Bush said I
want Trump there in the interests of
sort of unity and moving beyond
political disagreements that that we've
had but do you think that the other
people there want him there this is some
of the best video I've seen in a long
time and if we can put it back up what
once more Pat just to look at it again
pay particular attention not just to the
looks on the presidents and wives and
spouses faces but look at how Donald
Trump just looks miserable to be there
no I guess I have to say I even Dick
Cheney looking at him like what species
are you my friend I think that this is
exactly exactly how he should be treated
and I know that there were people who
will say it's childish for the Clintons
and the Carters and the Obamas to treat
Trump in this way no what's childish is
what Donald Trump has been doing for
three to four years at this point that's
actually what's embarrassing and it's
Trump and his followers who should be
embarrassed not the Clintons not the
Carters and certainly not the Obamas who
have been more than gracious to this guy
despite his disgusting behavior
one of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
dot coms mobile app or browser extension
for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from company's being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below